what's the skill set that's going to  make somebody good and this is six  figures still you have to learn how to  advertise so how do you let other people  know about the stuff you sell you have  to advertise there's six ways you can do  it and then once people engage with  whatever advertisement you have you have  to sell out advertising is the first  skill selling them as the second skill  product would be the third skill which  is the thing that you're ultimately  advertising and selling okay so that  gets the six figures what gets us that  same thing consistently just the act of  doing the same thing every day usually  gets people to 100 000 a month use  something that I call the rule 100 it's  100 primary actions whether that's 100  minutes of content creation per day 100  reach outs per day you have to pick one  of them but 100 per day and you do that  for 100 days and I promise you'll have  you'll be making six figures if you do  that